Is the best test to show me if my cancer is stable or in revision?
Well, there isn't a best test. It's a collaboration between many tests.
So, you know, you go from the most invasive, like a Pat scan or a CT scan to the lesser side of invasive this.
And MRI to go down that pathway of lesser invasive this ultrasound to the blood work.
So, I don't want to do another pet scan, but I feel like I'm doing real well.
So, the objective side of that testing would be blood work.
And you look at the blood work as a whole. So, you look at, if I have no metastasis,
then I would look at alkaline phosphatase, calcium levels, liver, other liver function tests, kidney function tests,
look at anemia numbers.
In the blood test, you would look for things like that.
And then you could look at, if you showed positive tumor markers in the past, you could use that as a helpful indication of whether you're going in the right direction or the wrong direction.
But there isn't anyone test that's going to say, yes, I'm in remission or yes, I'm doing greater.
Or the opposite of, oh no, I'm doing much worse.
You take each test gives you clues.
So, you take as many data points as you possibly can and you formulate a decision, clinical decision making process.
Plus you add subjective findings into that as well.
So, that's how you make the best differential diagnosis.
And that's how you best make the best clinical decisions.
You know, I talked to somebody today who they said, it was an alternative oncologist's person is going to.
So, they are recommending a keyboard pill that this person is on.
And then they did a DNA test on the person of the DNA circulated tumor cell levels were elevated.
Therefore, they said the oncologist said your cancer is getting worse.
We need to increase and put you on a platinum based medication, chemotherapy, because the cancer is getting worse.
And I was like, well, hold on a second.
What was the other data?
Was it solely based upon circulated tumor cells increased?
And this person wasn't for sure, but said, yes, because they had just had a CT scan and CT scan was normal.
There was no growth.
And she said her blood work was all under control.
Well, it's like, okay, we can't make major clinical decision making based upon one piece of data.
I just don't think that's correct.
I don't think that's fair to the patient.
I mean, yeah, if you're going to change their supplements or something like that, but if you're telling them to go on a medication that could alter their life forever,
based upon one piece of data, when other data show that they're doing well, I just don't think that's proper practice.
It sounds like the entire Zoom call here, I'm kind of grabbing about other practitioners and I don't need to do that, but I want you to be wise enough to discern what is going to be right care for you.
Because you're going to other practitioners.
So I'm trying to help you discern these things.
So best test to show me if I cancer stable, there isn't one.
You look at all sorts of data points.
So doing blood work, doing scans, doing MRIs, looking at subjective data.
That's how the best way to know if you're going down the right path.